richard balsam is due to be executed on
September the 16th but an actress whose
greatest role was in a death row drama
is trying to save him
he's clearly innocent once a mistake is
made within a judicial system people
just do not want to admit that mistake
has been made so it becomes impossible
case after case after case to to redress
them
susan sarandon won the Best Actress
Oscar for her portrayal of a nun who
accompanies prisoners to the death
chamber
dead man walking was based on the life
of sister Helen Prejean
who had a cameo in the movie here they
are standing side by side 20 years later
the campaigning nun is due to witness
another man dying by lethal injection
it's not just the one except the death
penalty comfort him as he dies it's you
got to resist things that are wrong
just from the record of how many people
have been exonerated in Oklahoma you
would think that they would stop doing
it because they've been so many people
that have been proven to be innocent
they're over 20 in other countries you
know that was a good enough reason to
abolish the death penalty but in America
it doesn't seem to be everyone accepts
he didn't actually kill anyone the
murder victim was his boss Barry Van
Treece he owned a seedy motel and when
Van Treece was found beaten to death
with a baseball bat one of the motels
employees confessed to the killing
seen here publicly for the first time
his 19 year old Justin's needs police
interview in which detectives encouraged
him to implicate gossip in the murder in
return for testifying against gossip
Snead was given a prison sentence well
of course it was condemned to death both
trials nobody saw the video of the
confession where the police are
practically spoon-feeding him what he
that should say and offering him to have
a lesser sentence a petition with
thousands of signatures has been handed
over to the governor of Oklahoma Mary
Fallon but she's refused to intervene or
be interviewed about the case serrand
and accuses her of trying to protect her
political career by acting tough on
crime the governor of Oklahoma is just a
horrible person and a woman so it's even
more discouraging it's never because of
some kind of
consciousness-raising that these things
change it's always because of some kind
of embarrassment so this is where public
opinion can make a difference this is
where having letters sent the governor
can make a difference
dead man walking concluded with an
execution Susan Sarandon hopes the
Richard Glossip story has a different
ending in woods Sky News